you and mcgregor
actually did that i'm convinced this uh
there was no wires there was no vfx
there was no air jets or any of that
stuff no no weird guys in in green
outfits that you and mcgregor actually
use the force to throw back that that
vader stun that was 100 real and that
was hayden christensen too it was
actually hayden christensen actually
hayden christensen really burned his
face yeah that's what i'm scaring i'm
convinced i heard a rumor he took his
balls off as well no don't put that in
come on cut that out song we can't do
that
no
you gotta leave it in
i forbid it being edited out vader
castrati arrow to his balls
where are his balls
i mean that's something that i think was
actually going to be addressed when this
was still a movie just imagine if this
was the movie yeah so much was changed
from this being a movie that's what
we're going to be talking about today
hey welcome back to new rock stars
obi-wan kenobi on disney plus left many
of us hoping for more from this series
maybe a more fleshed out arc from the
inquisitor riva or a storyline with
fewer plot holes in the way that it
connects to a new hope in star wars
rebels maybe even more from obi-wan
kenobi's hookups with that jawa but now
that the original screenwriter is
actually telling all would this have
worked better as a movie well either way
so long as it still had vader screaming
tommy tommy your lungs are delicate yes
we must protect tommy's lungs though
that's my lungs at all costs by the way
movement to uh referring to that
relationship is bow chicka jawa
obi-wan kenobi's
um motion granted yes this is um
wookie leaks it's new rockstar's weekly
discussion of all the biggest news and
star wars i'm eric boss i'm here with
tommy bechtold and you may remember
before obi-wan kenobi these weeks tommy
and i would just fill
the gap with all kinds of chit chat
because we didn't have this priority of
covering a most recent episode obi-wan
kenobi so things are back off the rails
yeah with tommy and eric as they should
be because you know tommy and i just got
back from austin if you were there with
us at rtx in austin thank you so much
for coming out and uh tommy
unfortunately while he was there in the
hotel he could not come downstairs
because uh he was having some issues yes
health-wise how are you feeling now i am
feeling uh
much better uh my whole family has been
taken down by by the dragon of covid but
uh i went on vacation with 17 people and
i'm proud to say 12 of the 17 are now
covered positive so those are stats you
know in wolf of wall street when matthew
uh mcconaughey says those are rookie
numbers we got to pump those up when i
heard that just one of us tested
positive for covert i said those rookie
numbers we've got to pump those up
tootsie and then i gave them all cocaine
from my infected vial anyway i'm clearly
doing fine and my brain is not at all
broken so
well we we're going to get that brain
broken because
you learn to appreciate the pieces when
you have a broken tommy right yes
absolutely the pieces are more beautiful
in a lot of ways well uh speaking of
things being broken and reassembled uh
we're learning now this week that
obi-wan kenobi the six episode
mini-series is actually supposed to be a
movie and we're actually learning what
that movie was going to be and how it
was changed specifically we're talking
back in 2017 when it was being developed
as a film not a series the original
screenwriter or the co-screenwriter
name of stuart beatty has now opened up
in an interview with the direct telling
us what that story was going to look
like on the big screen as a standalone
event perhaps the first in a trilogy of
films we're going to go through those
alterations in this episode and assess
if obi-wan kenobi might have worked
better as a film what the shortcomings
were as a mini-series whether those can
be blamed on it being formatted as a
mini-series uh and why those changes
were made we're gonna you know we're not
gonna be hating on anything this episode
we still really loved obi-wan kenobi
overall as a mini-series yes i think we
both agree it stuck the landing but it
did leave us wanting more and i think
we're gonna have a broader discussion
here about the way lucasfilm is
developing stories as a miniseries and
when you have six episodes to chart out
sometimes
certain things get de-prioritized uh
certain things get focused more on and
it makes it a bit harder when you have
so many other great mini-series
happening
under the lucasfilm uh masthead things
like you know the book of boba fett you
have the mandalorian happening you're
having the soca happening you're having
clone wars and bad match still being uh
brought out so it's kind of hard to uh
to keep an equal priority uh the plates
spinning on all their axes uh so to
speak yes um um now uh thank you all so
much for supporting our channel by
purchasing our latest obsession kenobi
inspired empire's most wanted shirts we
are now sold out of those but be sure to
keep an eye out over at near
rockstarsmerch.com because uh andor is
coming at the end of this summer for
certain we will have a shirt on about
that and there's plenty of other amazing
merch options you can get over at new
york's version i'm pushing for headbands
i'm hoping before sooner than later
beautiful headbands with gorgeous
catchphrases i sounded like trump on
that your beautiful headbands perfect
every time i'm in the street people come
to me and say i love your headbands
thank you so much for your headbands
yeah
he's just like they're always trying to
cancel our headbands yeah they want to
take away the headbands we love that
we're not doing anything with the
headbands we're going to bring the
headbands back the headbands will be
back then i can tell you that i can tell
you very much
oh god our subscribers are like everyone
all everyone watches like enough of this
no i don't i just
let us die
let me
let the past die kill it
um all right what are we talking about
this week on wikileaks i'm going to i'm
going to switch it up and throw you a
little curveball here what the fennec
shand would obi-wan kenobi have looked
like as a film
i like that yeah i just felt like fennek
needed a shout out you know i'm a big
fan she did
she did okay so originally obi-wan
kenobi was going to be a film this was
being developed in 2017 it was going to
be directed by stephen daldry and
written by hussein amini and stuart
beatty solo a star wars story of course
came out in 2018 the movie
underperformed lucasfilm uh i would say
maybe learned some of the wrong lessons
from that but just kind of freaked out
across the board about some of these
spin-off movies and end up delaying
kenobi but then after the success of the
mandalorian in early 2019 they're like
well everything should be that so they
reconceived obi-wan kenobi as a
miniseries they brought a new writer
joey harold and then a new director
deborah chow actually pixar's andrew
stanton who was uh helping out with the
mandalorian also jumped in and helped
out with some of the rewrites on a few
of the episodes of obi-wan kenobi now
hosseina mini and stuart beatty still
received some writing credits on some of
the episodes in their final drafts
because they did ultimately the
producers keep keeping a lot of their
story elements but now beady did an
interview with the direct going into
extended details spilling all the tea
about what how different his version of
the story was and it is fascinating to
read it this guy holds nothing back
because we never get insight like this
tommy remember there were some rumors
about jj abrams original vision for
episode nine the duel of the fates cut
but that was never confirmed it was just
kind of speculated about by various you
know scoopers from concept art this is
the guy who actually wrote it saying
right this is what my version was i
don't know why they change it here's how
i feel about it this is from the horse's
mouth as they say directly from it and
uh so just gonna quickly recap the
bigger changes uh from the original
obi-wan kenobi film draft from amini and
beady so in that draft riva would have
been the only inquisitor the grand
inquisitor the fifth brother the other
inquisitors would not have been in this
movie and uh the reason why petey didn't
want that is he didn't he wanted to
avoid any kind of continuity issues with
rebels because he knew the grand
inquisitor was going to come back in
rebels and he didn't want to like mess
with that too much also if we knew that
he would come back it kind of uh limits
how much you can
change about that character yeah um and
uh yeah
you know the version we got they kind of
did this goofy fake out where they
killed him off but we knew he wasn't
really dead right anyway also in this
original version riva would not have
initially known that darth vader was
anakin skywalker so riva she was still
going to be a survivor of the jedi purge
but she would have held the jedi council
responsible for everything that happened
to her and that would have been what
motivated her of hunting the jedi as an
inquisitor and instead it would have
been obi-wan who told riva that anakin
is vader and that would have been the
linchpin moment that changed her mind
and turned her rage redirected it
against vader and then that would have
led to rita lyon and telling vader that
she killed kenobi and vader in anger for
taking that kill from him would have
killed her kind of a dooku execution
style right
um
also throughout this original draft riva
would have instead of being teamed up
with other inquisitors she would have
led a group of elite stormtroopers akin
to u.s marshals all of these being
former clone troopers played by or at
least voiced by to wear morrison their
leader would have been a former clone
trooper named commander jet uh tamora
morrison also would have played the
returning commander cody joining obi-wan
on tatooine as a companion who looks
after luke skywalker when obi-wan leaves
the planet so in beady's draft commander
cody would have initially tracked down
kenobi and he would have thought uh oh
cody's gonna try to kill obi-wan but
then he pulls him into an alley with a
dagger and says you have to be more
careful and we learn that cody had had
his bio chip removed and feels guilty
for everything he did kind of like
almost like a rex scenario yeah like
bricks with ahsoka and rebels like the
the chip didn't really turn them
completely evil um there were going to
be some amazing scenes on tatooine with
kenobi and cody disposing of
stormtroopers who tried to track down
obi-wan throwing their corpses into the
sarlacc i love that they're like i would
have liked that oh the body's here
sabor morrison was basically going to be
like mike myers in uh on austin powers
movie and just played 9 000 roles he was
just going to be like he's austin powers
he's doctor evil
bastards
[Laughter]
um there was also gonna be a scene with
a really drunk jawa we got a little
trace of that with tikka in episode one
uh wasn't drunk which is kind of uh
tricky and then uh so this is where i
think it gets very interesting in this
original draft kenobi was going to meet
up with a group of jedi refugees as as
he does in the show but in the movie
draft kenobi's disconnect from the force
would have been more pronounced more
explicit more of a thematic focus as
opposed to like kind of an undercurrent
that you can derive from some of the
lines um so when he meets the refugees
obi-wan would have met one particular
refugee named tao tao in tao would have
told obi-wan about their religion
describing it as a goddess that they
worship and would have taken him to a
shrine for this goddess and obi-wan
would have put his hands on the shrine
to commune with this goddess but when he
goes into that communication with the
goddess so we want to realize oh this is
just the force they just have a
different name for the force uh and then
that would have led obi-wan to wake up
in a vision of himself on mustafar a
nightmare sequence that was going to be
similar to luke in the dagobah cave in
empire strikes back and then on mustafar
obi-wan would have seen a dark-hooded
figure with a red lightsaber he assumed
it would have been anakin called out to
it anakin anakin figure turns around
it's actually luke age 19. this they
would have brought in a dh mark hamill
for this this would have led to a duel
and obi-wan would have realized two
important things one that he still needs
the force
and two that he needs to keep luke from
becoming his oh my god i wouldn't so
ultimately ask my pants if i saw that i
mean now this is just coming from stuart
beatty who knows what was actually in
his draft he could have just you know
because he said he could have been
winging it like an improv show
and then i was going to have her
he's doing the patent oswald monologue
from community
or parks and rec i mean yeah for sure it
just sounds like the coolest elements of
this draft were excluded from the
miniseries because unfortunately other
lucasfilm titles just kind of beat them
to the punch like his early version of
riva really kind of ended up being
trilla suduri from jedi fallen order the
dh mark hamill of course came up in the
mandalorian season two tamara morrison
and the sarlacc obviously came back up
in the book of boba fett i just think
the writing of riva remains the central
problem with the scripts of these six
episodes because it's never really
explained how riva knows that anakin was
vader other than like oh well he
attacked me that night and i just kind
of recognized from the way he uses a
lightsaber i mean it was just kind of
unstated so it was forcing like the fans
and the viewers and youtubers to kind of
be like well maybe that's how she knew
you know kind of using this logic of
well you know thrawn was able and able
to know but also thrawn is like a
strategic genius who recognizes certain
maneuvers in a fighter so i mean i think
we're willing to give a thrawn a pass
because we knew so much else about it
but revo you know the rest of her
behavior isn't exactly like brilliant
brilliant strategy that she's using so
it's harder to give her the benefit of
that doubt also i gotta say i think
riva's rivalry with the other
inquisitors just feels a bit
underdeveloped and the inquisitors as a
whole do not come off as an as
intimidating as they do in rebels or in
fallen order i think the inquisitors are
really done dirty on this series uh and
i i think this series really just makes
the unnecessary choice of delaying the
reveal of riva's order 66 backstory
until episode five when we were all able
to conclude it anyway and instead we
were just kind of questioning her
actions episode episode uh and i think
if they had just opened with it we could
have uh tracked her decisions uh beat to
beat instead of being you know them
shrouded in a mystery and also this
series keeps in a really odd detail like
one of riva's best friends one of those
other younglings suspended in amber as a
corpse in that fortress tomb yeah like
shouldn't we have gotten at least one
moment with riva in that kid like if
that's motivating everything she does
why is she okay with just leaving it on
display there um she seems to have like
completely unchecked power especially
when the grand inquisitor is indisposed
she could have easily gotten that corpse
out of there and given him a proper
barrier yeah yeah i think ultimately uh
riva was intended initially to be a
character who dies so that vader and
obi-wan don't have to kill each other it
makes sense obviously they can't either
of them cannot die in this story if they
come back right in rogue one slash a new
hope it just feels a little cheap to let
riva survive this story now as the
miniseries did uh instead the miniseries
killed off tala who i think is a far
more interesting character with clearer
motivation so i was more excited to see
what she does in the future so tommy i
want to bring you in on this what what
other story beats do you think might
have suffered from obi-wan kenobi being
a six-chapter series on disney plus as
opposed to a film you know i think
that
we definitely lost
and not necessarily for bad reason but i
mean the owen
baru luke stuff all kind of got pushed
is kind of prologue epilogue right like
it was like not necessarily epilogue but
like in terms of the leia and kenobi
rescue story
and getting leia home safe
those elements got pushed out we
probably would have had more tatooine
luke origins and this would have
probably this to me this kenobi movie
feels like episode
3.5 more than anything right like it
kind of feels like a
like a like a fourth prequel movie
rather than a uh in the skywalker
trilogy for lack of a better you know
like
skywalker uh saga rather for lack of a
better way to put it so i think we
definitely lost that although i so
enjoyed the princess leia elements of
the movie or of this of the miniseries
so i can't thoroughly complain about
that i also think like
the
the whole jedi path thing got kind of
like the the concept of the path got
kind of not necessarily
done any justice or made it given us any
more answers or left us at a like oh
we're definitely going to go back to
o'shea jackson junior's character and
figure out what's going on with a path
in a future story you know what i mean
like i feel like
i don't know i i don't know uh
how they would have it doesn't seem like
there was much mention of that in the
film from that interview but i wonder if
that was stuff that was added in later
and i and i wonder if that was even
necessary you know like all that yeah
hearing all of this now makes it feel
like that stuff was what they changed
and added to it yeah i think it was
necessary in fact i think that was more
necessary than leia was yeah as much as
i loved leia coming into this series
when you and i were at a star wars
celebration and we saw the leia scene
when as soon as we saw the skyline of
alderaan i was like
like my heart melted and i love the
beats and and the finale where they
connect and we hear the leia theme come
in like that was all beautiful but i
think if it is obi-wan's story
i don't think i needed an obi-wan leia
relationship sure i think it was the
relationship should have been i'm saying
should have been i don't want to
gatekeep i ultimately i don't want to
complain too much but it it sounded like
the original vision for this was it was
about obi-wan's relationship with the
force right nobody wants a relationship
with anakin yeah it's kind of it's kind
of like uh it's like a superhero story
of someone getting their powers back
right like it's like someone who lost
who buried their powers
or like law or
lost their powers because of some
traumatic incident and then it's the
quest to get that back to save uh the
next generation and also just to
slightly defend you on our show i don't
think you're gatekeeping the whole
premise of this was just theorizing you
know and discuss it so i think you're go
easy on yourself be nice be nice to my
friend eric it's okay
no i refuse to be nice eric voss is dead
you didn't kill eric voss i did
[Laughter]
i think if you're looking at other uh
examples to pull from a story like
unforgiven you know clint eastwood the
90s movie a great like western
deconstruction uh if you didn't see
unforgiven you can just watch logan the
wolverine movie from 2017. it's
essentially the same plot uh similar
stories right you're protecting the
welfare of a kid it's old like a
grizzled hermit who's pulled out of
retirement uh and has to find his inner
badass once again um both of those
stories ended up being fascinating
movies as a film lover to look at
because they are deconstructions of
mythology itself of what it means to be
a badass western hero and they really
deconstruct that and actually point out
actually our relationship to violence as
a consumers of stories is something
worth
critiquing
because
we think we're ready for violence we
think we want to see a lone gunslinger
uh wreck a bar but we are actually
not as uh deserving or
needing that kind of violence and uh
they have characters in both those
stories who say i i'm not right for this
world um and i hate to see you return to
this level of violence um and i think
obi-wan could have been that i i think
obi-wan could have shown like been a
character who's like i don't want to
live that violent world anymore is there
a way for me to remove myself from the
violence especially knowing that obi-wan
as a character is doomed in a lot of
ways we know what's going to happen to
him on the death star right uh so for
him to have that kind of reluctance for
for you know for luke to train him for
him to be haunted by what he did to
anakin uh i think there could have been
some interesting new thematic statements
that were made instead uh we just kind
of had his journey
attract with his relationship with leia
and it opened up this story for so many
landmines when it came to logical issues
with you know what we know his destiny
lies ahead with with leia um
and i think uh you did not need leia in
the story ultimately uh i think that was
uh both a gift and a curse to the story
i think it uh it robbed us of scene
of truly understanding what obi-wan's
journey was instead
we had episode after episode of leia
being re-kidnapped but you couldn't do
it in any way that actually gave us a
real concern for what leia's welfare was
going to be because we know she was
going to survive sure um i honestly
would have preferred
uh what would have happened if like
you know benny safety's character in the
first episode could have been someone
else someone who we had more stakes with
that uh that obi-wan uh had some kind of
new relationship with or if just riva if
we were established through flashback
that obi-wan had an ahsoka-like
mentorship
uh with another padawan uh another not
another padawan but another young lane
in the temple and then that uh
they see each other face to face again
on tatooine and he is now brought back
like oh you were one of these other kids
in the temple that i had this
affection for
and now look at you oh [ __ ] and then it
just becomes like a cat and mouse game
between them for six episodes
don't need leia in it right i think it
would have been completely fine just to
see obi-wan's relationship through with
the force through the eyes of this uh
second sister like or now in this case
the third sister like inquisitor who
hates him for abandoning her for uh you
know instead gallivanting on udapa
fighting uh grievous so
lies hello there and now he just cringes
regretting being ever involved with the
clone wars i just think like the
hopefully the lesson learned here is
that as fun as it is for dh mark hamill
to show up or for a younger actor to
play leia in a story
the best parts about
the mandalorian are just these new
characters it's just the relationship
between din jaren and grogu names that
never existed among star wars fans
before 2019. we are totally okay just
exploring
new characters and relationships that uh
and obviously if it's a show about
obi-wan kenobi it can just be about
obi-wan kenobi the show did not need to
be obi-wan kenobi and leia
yeah
and bail organa and all these other
things as much as we hear new rock stars
talk about what famous names will cameo
in things
ultimately we really just want to
see we want to be surprised sure and uh
just explore relationships i know a lot
of people will be like oh look at new
rock stars they're always just saying we
need a cameo in it ultimately no we
don't yeah we we do not need a cameo and
i think that that's really you know
thoughtful
thoughtful analysis because it it's
helpful because you're right like
it's the gift and the curse of of having
that that great young actress play leia
we were like lulled into like following
that story when ultimately it didn't
give us anything new and it only created
new problems not like new compelling you
know storytelling it was like oh we
already know that both of these
characters are gonna be fine so it's
like you're having us follow the the
great chase
to hunt down and kill two characters we
know that that's never gonna happen so
yeah i i i i yeah i think that's really
really compelling and i think that's
what uh hopefully the lesson that is
applied and already understood as we see
new uh star wars titles on the horizon i
think that's why i'm probably most
excited by the acolyte
which is something that just takes place
in the distant past there's gonna be no
familiar characters in there hopefully
none and we have no idea what the fates
of these characters are uh and hopefully
we're gonna talk about andor in the
second half of this episode um there's
potentially some issues there because we
know what you know cassian andor's fate
is we know what mon mothma and bail
organa's fates are if ahsoka shows up on
the show we know what her fate or we
kind of know what her fate is
i mean there's still a lot of questions
i guess we have about ahsoka but i think
they're smartly bringing in a lot of new
characters that we've never heard of
before and that's kind of where you need
to go you need to have the right balance
of new versus familiar but uh before we
talk about andor uh we want to thank
raycon for sponsoring this episode if
you're listening to wikileaks right now
as a podcast are you listening on raycon
earbuds because that's how i listen to
this on any other podcast and you should
too raycon's everyday earbuds look feel
and sound better than ever with
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit their earbuds are super
comfortable and better locked in than an
x-wings targeting system yes raycons
offer three sound profiles to match what
you're listening to plus noise isolation
and awareness mode so you can choose to
be immersed in sound or be able to hear
your surroundings when you need to i
really like using them around the house
like when i'm making dinner doing chores
they're super secure and they sound
great raycons give you eight hours of
play time and a 32 hour battery life you
can even do wireless charging with
raycons you get the same quality audio
as other premium audio brands but at
half the price it's no wonder raycon's
everyday earbuds have over forty nine
thousand five star reviews check out
raycon's wireless earbuds my guess is
that you're going to want to leave them
a five star review as well go to buy
recon dot com slash wookie today to get
15 off your recon order that's by
raycon.comwookie to score 15 off by
raycon.comwookie that's with two e's all
right tommy let's get back to talking
about andor yeah so this week we
actually learned how they're gonna space
out the timeline of andor across its two
seasons tony gilroy told empire that
season one will focus on the first year
of andor joining the rebel cause but
season two is going to follow the next
four years leading up to rogue one
season two's twelve episodes will be
split up into four three batch arcs so
uh the first three episodes will be
focused on the second year of this
journey the uh second three episodes
will be about the third year of the
journey the
third three episodes we'll be focusing
on the fourth year and the final three
episodes will be on that final year
dovetailing right into rogue one so i
kind of looking ahead now and we were
just talking about uh familiar
characters versus new characters we know
uh stalin skarsgard is going to be
playing lutheran uh we got uh uh
what's-her-face from uh from the harry
potter films and petunia that actually
oh yeah an actress is gonna be playing
another restaurant she's amazing do you
think season uh
two might be field feeling more like
clone wars with arcs jumping around in
time like different locations different
missions different characters three
episodes at a time what do you think
interesting so almost serialized where
it's like you know the characters are
the same but the but the k we get a
beginning middle and conclusion in every
episode
i mean
i almost feel like that's a better thing
to that that that to me is more
interesting
for a character like andor it would be
way too hard to do that with obi-wan
because of all the history but a
character like cassie and ander that we
just have this one movie and then you
know i think i think some novels right
like there's been some cassini indoor
books that are out i don't i don't know
i have to i'll have to
tell me in the comments i'm sure you
will but uh i think having him do
complete missions in each episode will
give us way more information about the
character in the new characters than
trying to tell us a whole story that
once again we know
does not end it ends great in his
heroicism but does not end great in his
uh living and breathing you know right
right exactly uh i think it's gonna our
our concerns are gonna be more of these
peripheral characters who we need uh
stalin skarsgard's characters uh there's
gonna be plenty of new characters in
fact i think what seems so smart about
the andorra footage so far and the way
tony gilroy is building this is it's
mostly familiar like we haven't even
seen bail organa or socatano or any of
these people show up it's real the only
familiar faces are mon mothma and uh and
cassian andor himself
um so i think there's an opportunity
here um to just show it's kind of like
what star wars rebels did is just show
the rebellion uh in like different
missions that are happening uh as like
we know that they fail to stop the rise
of the death star so that's going to be
the one thing that eludes them
throughout this process but there are
going to be other weapons that we know
about that are being built like for
example we know sabine wren right she
was an imperial weapons officer um and
there were other like superweapons that
were being built that were vicious uh so
those things are going to be uh targeted
by this rebel group you know those types
of things um other horrible war crimes
that the empire's committing that they
may help uh liberate some like labor
camps or yes uh or other occupied
populations uh and recruiting them to
join the rebel cause absolutely i i i
think that we will like you said we're
gonna have we're gonna have new
characters introducing new new things
and i'm also interested to see like with
that time period of right before a new
hope like we're really butting into like
some
there is potential for
some some people we've already seen in
these live-action tv shows to return it
in younger form so yeah maybe a black
chrysanthemum showing why not hey i mean
get that guy back out there and we just
got off of saying like
i think though the cameos are okay if
they are just cameos you don't need to
build entire storylines
you know i'm just a sucker for it yeah
how fun was it when uh like when leia
appeared it it leia really could have
worked in obi-wan kenobi if she would
just showed up at the end when obi-wan's
chatting with bale and then leia shows
up in the background i think that would
have had the same kind of impact and
same kind of effect yeah yeah because
that's all cameos need to be you don't
need to like hinge an entire storyline
on a returning character hey we'll leave
it there for this episode of wikileaks
but we want to ask you to again to check
out our great merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com you can follow me at
eavos follow tommy and tell me back to
follow the rockstar subscribe to
wikileaks wherever you get your podcast
thank you so much for watching we're
going to see you every monday going
forward until we get to andor up until
then thank you for watching
we have spoken
you